hey guys today i'm going to show you how
to make internet explorer
faster
first of all let me show you how fast
well about how fast um i have my
internet explorer running at right now
it's not the fastest web browser ever
let's try
real quick youtube.com
see how long this takes
as you can see it's not speed by any
means
so let's exit out of this i want to take
you through
the steps to make internet explorer
faster
first we're going to go to the start
menu
in xp this will work well if you're one
running windows xp you're gonna hit run
if you're not if you're on vista just
type
regedit
as in your registrator
hit continue
and it'll bring up ridgid and i'm going
to give you this whole list of
instructions on how to do this
um in the description so just check down
there also watch this in hd it's much
easier to see these values
so we're going to go to h key current
user expand it
we're going to go to
we're going to go to
uh software
so let's find
software expand that
and we go to microsoft
yeah there we go expand that
and go to
current
convert oh no wait hold on microsoft and
windows
so let's look for
w windows expand windows
then go to current version expand it
and last but not least internet settings
and don't expand this click on the
folder
so what we're going to do
is
if you don't have it already well first
of all i'll show you what happens if you
do have it
go and find the name
max connections
one underscore zero server
double click this to modify it
i'm going to set mine to
99.
if you only want incremental
improvements 10
20 etc if you set it to 100 or above
things have been known to go wrong so
i'm going to set mine to 99
okay
and then i'm going to go to max
connections per
server set mine
to 99
also this should be a decimal value
this should be a decimal value
99
and this should be decimal value
99 all right
that is the first step to making
internet explorer faster
if you don't already have these values
in your reg edit all you need to do is
right click and hit new and d word
32-bit value you're going to name the
new value exactly what you see here mass
per one underscore zero server
and set it as a decimal value 99 then
you go to and name another one max
connections per server and make it a
decimal value 99
i'm going to delete this one because i
already have them
and that is the registry editing portion
of how to make internet explorer faster
secondly
you can do
this um you can open up internet
explorer
oh crap
i should have saved that uh go open up
internet explorer again
and we're going to go to tools
and delete browsing history
doing this every week or so will
definitely help speed up internet
explorer
there we go it's deleting browsing
history
but if you haven't already done so you
should download ccleaner which makes
this whole process a whole lot easier
run the c cleaner
deletes all your temporary internet
files
next what you want to do
what you want to do here is go to tools
internet options
and here it will say browsing history go
to settings
and we're going to say
um
days to keep pages in history and you
can see that excuse the flashing
days to keep pages in history
i'm going to select that
hit zero
and press ok
and that will prevent us from ever
having to refresh again
so i'm going to exit an internet
explorer and pull it up one last time
and see
if it's any faster i already had a lot
of these settings applied already
so
it's not going to show a huge difference
but you can tell already it started
buffering the page earlier um the last
time
actually that was my computer as well
if you haven't hit that subscribe button
already do so
do so
um so that is how i make an internet
explorer 7 faster
if
um if you do not have internet explorer
7 i highly suggest upgrading if you have
ie 6 or anything lower
to find out what version you have
um
i forgot how to find out what version
you have but make sure you have internet
explorer seven
so
that is how you increase your speed of
internet explorer seven in windows xp
and windows vista if
if you have
if you're still using internet explorer
i'll have to tell you now it's not the
fastest web browser let me just say
safari by comparison
and
enter here
so that's that's how much faster it is
so i'll just
you know
give me that and um i'll make a video i
think i already have on how to make
safari faster
so um
yeah i hope you enjoyed this video and
enjoy your new internet speed the
instructions i will try to make in the
description box so subscribe peace out